fortnite was the first crazy really and
among us was the second crazy yeah
what's the next crazy gonna be yeah i
don't think not valor i [ __ ] hate
valorance so much there will be one for
a really long time
oh thank you oh you're right yeah yeah i
despise that everyone plays valerian so
much i feel like it's the most boring
game i've ever played in my life
paying fifty dollars for a [ __ ] skin
oh you're scared
it's cause i'm bad okay that's why i'm
bad at the game okay if you can't beat
them
also
let's play
i'll make sure you have a great time you
should i i will have like if i do when
we're back in japan i'll have like 200
ping and you'll have to it's fine it's
playable i'll just be even [ __ ]
i wonder why you hate it
yeah i played on the japanese service
and he still sucks
everyone's insane on the japanese
i would go in the new rookie lobby and
it would be a 10 year old boy who's just
tried valentine for the first time
and then he's like oh yeah this is easy
boom just shoots everyone at the wall
and i'm like no you have to play while
you're here okay okay and you'll have
fun like actually like a five stack it's
hard not to have fun when you can talk
to your friends i think i'm just envious
i i'm like the boy looking outside in
the window with everyone else having fun
and i'm like oh i'm on the japanese side
for having fun without me actually that
makes a lot of sense that's probably why
that's why yeah i've actually been the
word valerian for my chat because i
don't want people asking me about
playing it because i'm i have like
trauma because i don't wanna
you need to stream it here enjoy it and
then just let it go you know like that's
just like that
just if you love it
i'll try i'm willing to try again if i
played with people i want to try again
on 200 ms i'm down to try actually on
america it's like 110 which is actually
way more playable than 200. i feel like
150 is the cutoff of when it becomes a
player really it is i've also played
league on like a hundred pages but 200
you just you can't it just sounds like
you're like trying to get him into a new
drug it's like it's it's not the drug
that was bad you just didn't do it with
the right people
i'm really against it
i think all riot games are a drug
except for uh league of runeterra i mean
that's just like legends of room terror
that's like cough syrup
you really need to but
yeah it's like the medicine your mom
forces you to take like okay here you go
there's good lore in it i swear to god
yeah i maybe i won't play it i just [ __ ]
i also just think that there's that
awkward moment when you die in the game
and then you're like i can't wait to
play the next round in five minutes but
at least it's not that long
sometimes it feels long and then you buy
[ __ ] and you're like i spent all my
money earlier it depends
i am very impatient i am the [ __ ] who
always runs first and then i die and
then i get angry because why am i
impatient it's my fault i suck at this
game that's why you love apex right yeah
she's constantly moving yeah i love
agents that make sense yeah
and also apex is so big in japan as well
and like all the v tubers and all the
japanese streamers [ __ ] love it wait
that's so cool yeah so it's fun it's fun
but then that's let's kind of die
offline
or i guess like on twitch in general i
feel like there's no meta right now yeah
yeah i was about to ask you like what do
you think the next better is going to be
on twitch
um
i think it's
in an odd way irl for a little bit okay
yes and in general like traffic on
twitch
a little bit right i think there's not
going to be like a huge game for a while
there's not going to be another
fortnight or among us yeah maybe for
years
or ever again
honestly that the only next thing i can
think of is like
among us
it has to be innovative the reason
fortnight was innovative was because it
was the first game to go mainstream the
reason among us was like innovative in a
way first game to go mainstream i don't
think it was the first there's been
games that got mainstream level
right there was nothing on the level of
like fortnight when you have celebrities
minecraft sports but it's not it's not
um yeah really or eating craft is like
not even cod it's like a staple in the
game i guess it's kind of a slow bone as
well
fortnight was a massive trend that went
mainstream and that happened
never been seen before within gaming
there's been large games obviously yeah
but it's always within gaming like if
you're not a gamer
that's right yeah yeah yeah you just
don't know about it right yeah um but
that with like celebrities playing it's
like nfl players yeah drake playing it
it went huge right among us was the
other big boom but it was because of
such a specific set of circumstances
yeah yeah the pandemic on top of it
being one of the first fun games that
had a really large player pool so like a
whole new level of collaboration right
oh yeah
honestly on twitch sometimes it feels
like been there done that with
everything
when is the next time there's gonna be
like something really new and innovative
it's hard to tell i feel like there
might have to be some sort of like tech
innovation
i i was i was like really uh against
like the thought of doing irl stuff i
thought this [ __ ] it's weird it's
going outside and then i then i did it
once because um
i did uh i
they gave me a backpack uh so i could do
the thing where i'd like take iron mouse
around and i was like okay actually this
is kind of fun yeah like what if like
what if like i did this and did like
something where i just got drunk or
something i don't know
i think it was really fun and then i'm
like okay i think they're my favorite
streamers i think though definitely in
the beginning when irl was becoming a
thing it didn't necessarily have like
the best reputation yeah people who were
doing it like a lot of the early people
were doing some really [ __ ] weird
yeah like that like the ice
yeah so i think just because of
of that
yeah when you hear the word irl
immediately it's like you think of
people like that it's like oh [ __ ] i
don't want to
get anywhere near that but obviously you
know now it's like you know you have
people like jake and bake and like
people who actually push the boundaries
of irl in a positive direction yeah like
a fun direction obviously so yeah the
barrier
if i lived in japan oh my god my irl
streams would never end i started doing
more
but i always want to do something
interesting i'm just like i don't want
to just [ __ ] walk around go
to an arcade i've been doing it
yeah
yeah go to a convenience store for six
hours honestly easy stream honestly
i would never do it
you're gonna do you're gonna have such a
fun time because like i forget
through the roof well the thing is sorry
pokemon my content is higher than that
okay i have higher standards yeah
no no listen him trying to like really
plan content this needs to be perfect i
don't plan it i i just twitch viewers i
can love convenience stores i
i think that's the difference between
being a youtuber and being a twitch
streamer right because like when i
stream i'm like i need to know what i'm
doing this needs to be planned i need to
struggle you need a narrative yeah
what's the youtube title what is the
youtube title okay honestly the worst
thing for a twitch stream is a narrative
or a story no no no no i'm okay i'm
against you there for repeated ones yeah
unless it's like an event or something
that you specifically announce yeah
right the reason youtube and live
streaming is so different and what works
best for live streaming is you want it
to be a form of content that people can
tune in at any point and it's enjoyable
i agree that's why like i think even
like a challenge yeah like when i've
i've been offered to do like cooking
streams where it's like this person
against this person i hate that stuff
yeah because someone has to watch from
the beginning middle and end and that's
just not how live streaming is that's
how a video oh man i kind of disagree in
some aspect there i yeah i'm i'm so in
the camp of uh because i only really
started streaming uh like two years ago
uh but it's been going really well it's
been doing well and um my whole
thought process around it is like make
the live stream obviously as a
interesting as possible but built around
the whole thing so it can fit nicely
it's like a 15-minute youtube video that
is literally how i plan all my streams
and i find that improves personally it
like improved my streams i'm trying to
hit those beats i'm trying to hit those
moments or i guess like um
how do you think that disagrees with my
point or how do you try to make it into
a 15 minute video should you mean like
intro
because i agree those things are good
yeah i guess just having a basic goal to
work towards yeah yeah like there is
goals yeah yeah like one general goal
because like
whenever someone does enter the stream
like i think that's kind of in agreement
if anything because whenever someone
stream they're like oh you're trying to
make five thousand dollars on gta and
you're this far and it's easy
it would have to be something that can
be explained in the title that's my way
of doing it as well that's really good
because it's also the same with youtube
right i got to hook them and it has to
fit in the thumbnail and a title so
that's kind of the way i plan most of my
things but sometimes yeah i think that's
like
that's third eye opening content
creation no in a good way when you're a
twitch streamer and you think about how
to make a twitch stream a youtube video
before making this like you have your
thumbnails
and then you make the content and then
it's a full stream and then it's a video
like yeah yeah
it's it's it's full circle yeah yeah
cause like i feel like a goddamn god
yeah because i've been trying i've been
trying to do that as well recently and
i'm not a twitch streamer at all but
i've like been dabbling in twitch
streams and i notice
the best streams that i do is something
that has that the audience can follow
that has like a specific goal or an end
game yeah um i don't think that's good
because it's good for viewer attention
yeah yeah yeah yeah i want to watch this
goal finish yeah yeah exactly yeah as
long as it's an achievable goal i did um
i did like the jump king stuff and i
love jump king i know but i did
i did uh one of the fan made mods that
like ludwig did and miss gifted that
took them like 40 hours and i was like
i'm better than them i'll do it and uh
yeah it took me like 40 minutes more
than ludwig and i was like i'm never
[ __ ]
yeah and it was it was like eight
streams and it was just like
but the viewers by like stream six were
like can you just
can you stop can we do you do something
else can you [ __ ] stop please dad you
haven't fed us and it's so sad it's like
that is eight streams that i did to make
one youtube video that's one youtube
video but it's such a [ __ ] good
youtube video because it's like it's
like you see the journey you get like
the multiple days and it's like a whole
thing that's good but you're starving
have you played getting over it i think
that's a great i've done i did that in
three hours yeah he's he's done all the
rage games yeah he went through a phase
oh so it was an addiction well it wasn't
a difference here's my thing and uh
obviously because i i started doing this
and i realized the whole youtube thing
and i knew i noticed that like ludwig
was doing it really well and i was
messaging ludwig and i'm like hey how do
you make your streams and he told me the
same thing and i was like okay so i kind
of like just i'm like oh my god logic's
just doing this but better i'm like i'm
just gonna copy ludwig so i started um i
started doing all the i also wanted to
beat him in things so i started doing
the same thing the same games that he
was doing and i did pogo stock have you
played this game
it's [ __ ] hard jump king is like
nothing compared to this game it is
miserable i can do getting over it i
can't do jumping i love jump kings so
streamer two if i can't finish it within
a two streams get pissed off okay okay
well jump king you can beat in two shots
i beat hell
how long
like maybe
three hours two or three times that's
nothing that's not i know it's good you
gotta you gotta get in there for the
long haul
i will depression
i i the one challenge right that he did
that i was like i'm not [ __ ] doing
this i beat pogo stuck the first one and
that's like the easiest of the three and
it took me 30 hours which is less than
all the other ones but i was like this
was such a miserable experience that i'm
like i'm just not doing the other ones
yeah you could finish a grpg in that
time yeah yeah you can you can mock me
louder you can hold it against me [ __ ]
off i'm not doing it
this is too [ __ ] you're just because
he did it when he was a small streamer
and it didn't matter if he had no
concurrent viewers or something
do this because they're like oh what's
he doing today i can't wait
not again it's like no so then now i'm
trying to focus more on stuff that could
be done in two or one yeah obviously
yeah
it's really fun yeah
people to jump in and watch yeah i think
that's that's the strap make a stream so
that if they if they miss it they can
watch the vod if they they want to watch
the highlight they can do it but they
can just come next to the next day
there'll be something completely new
yeah exactly
um i feel like maybe the next meta will
be something like pokemon go no really
no
irl
something oh
okay
so not pokemon go but maybe something
else so you think irl will play a big
part i think whatever i think so yes
because i don't know like i've done like
one irl stream after like
dissing irl streamers for like the
longest time and i'm like damn it's like
really fun i can see why people do it
yeah yeah yeah
because yeah i mean all like all you do
is just do what you'd normally do
yeah you'd be a human it's a whole new
way of streaming like it's a new
experience for the streamer and a new
experience oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i thought for sure the first time i did
it i thought i would immediately hate it
yeah just because again like i had that
like connotation about irl yeah i did it
once and i'm like yeah i want to do it
again but yeah it's good for the like
you do it once or twice two three times
a month i could not do it every day no i
can't do it every day people the people
who do it every day i'm like how the
[ __ ] do you do you like enjoy life yeah
how would you find enough things to do
every day you don't they don't yeah yeah
yeah sometimes they just live in japan
you probably could well
look at people like rob cd who literally
does an irl stream like every day yeah
and i'm just and jake back in the day
right when he was in japan i'm like how
do you
how do you do it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i like my privacy
too yeah
i like enjoying my food in restaurants
yeah i like having a good time i would
start forgetting like am i streaming or
not yeah yeah just walking around
exactly i get confused yeah i'm like
sometimes i'm like okay i've touched a
bit too much grass recently
i i need to go back here
i need to go back to my [ __ ] cave
become a hermit for a bit